je vais vous dire depuis le disque le
téléphone pleure je crois que j'ai pas
vu un engouement comme ça vraiment fort
comme ça depuis ça
il y avait les pubs et les Spike il y a
désormais les Beyblade des jouets en
forme de toupie que s'arrache les jeunes
du monde entier depuis leur lancement au
Japon en 2001 dans l'archipel le
phénomène fait en ce moment sensation
auprès des écoliers de l'offensive à la
défensive en passant par l'endurance et
la balance les toupies qui occupent une
place de choix dans les cartables ont
été conçues pour combattre il ne fallait
pas plus pour captiver nos chers têtes
blondes reportage à Saint-Pierre
d'Hélène Lecomte et Claude
hyper vitesse
qu'est-ce que vous dites là au début de
chaque combat hyper vitesse c'est un
petit truc comme ça c'est pour avertir
quand on tire
et ça se dit dans le dessin animé ou
c'est vous qui l'avez inventé
si vous demandez à un enfant âgé de 5 à
12 ans quel est son jeu préféré il y a
de fortes chances qu'il vous répondent
la toupie Beyblade
depuis un bon mois une véritable folie
souffle sur l'archipel à l'origine de
cet engouement le dessin animé diffusé
sur une chaîne du câble depuis début
janvier ou de gentil héros s'affrontent
par le biais de toupie combattante du
coup un véritable phénomène
d'identification s'est produit et les
petits arrachent littéralement la
reproduction de ces toupies pourtant
c'est jouir Voltan étaient déjà présents
sur les étals des magasins spécialisés à
Noël ils avaient été alors totalement
boudé depuis un mois victime de leur
succès les toupies tant convoités se
vendent comme des petits pains et les
commerçants doivent faire face à une
demande de plus en plus pressante
il y en aura que vendredi après-midi et
il nous reste des stadiums des petits et
des gants je vais vous dire depuis le
disque le téléphone pleure je crois que
j'ai pas vu un engouement comme ça
vraiment un fort comme ça depuis ça vous
en avez vendu combien par exemple pour
l'instant alors pour l'instant je dois
en avoir vendu plus de 300
et combien vous allez en vendre encore
là j'en attends encore 200
tu viens chez une toupie alors tu as un
selfie et les fans du dessin animé ne
s'en laisse pas compter lumineux en
acier ou à billes pour un investissement
allant de 4 à 14 euros en moyenne ils
ont une idée extrêmement précise de la
toupie de leurs rêves
le dessous est blanc et le dessus est
rose il y en a qui disent que c'est le
métal dragon
pour certains le phénomène toupie est
devenu presque un mode de vie accéléré
une équipe avec des amis et consacre
tout leur temps libre à cette nouvelle
passion Axel ça fait ça fait combien de
temps là en fait que tu joues comme ça
aux toupie tu oublies ça fait environ
un petit mot
comment ça tu es venu cette passion là
quand j'ai vu le dessin animé
j'ai apprécié
elle est réglementaire
sont loin d'être les seuls la jouer du
lanceur et du petit objet rond leur
camarades de classe en possède tous en
moyenne deux exemplaires mais à partir
de la quatrième les adolescents semblent
se désintéresser de ces jeux de combat
leur argent de poche est investi dans
d'autres divertissements parce que la
folie des toupies a un coût et pas des
moindres
moi un petit peu plus c'est à peu près
euros ça fait beaucoup
1 2 3
qu'est-ce qui te plaît en fait dans le
fait de faire de la toupie c'est amusant
quand même un truc qui était c'est pas
vraiment nouveau comme ça les toupies
mais là ils ont sorti quelque chose
j'aime bien
autre lieu de prédilection des acharnés
de la toupie l'école primaire le virus a
depuis plusieurs semaines contaminées le
milieu scolaire et les cours de
récréation deviennent de véritables
terrains de jeux mais contrairement à ce
que l'on pourrait croire les enseignants
voient l'épidémie d'un bon œil la
concentration et la non-violence
qu'engendre l'exercice assure le calme
relatif des enfants il y a pas
d'interdits déjà aux règlements
intérieurs de l'école qui stipule dans
l'article 1 qu'en interdit les
téléphones portables les objets
dangereux voir les cigarettes à fortiori
bien sûr donc c'est pas un objet
contondant c'est pas un objet coupant et
il a plutôt il est plutôt un facteur
d'apaisement qu'autre chose donc il est
parfaitement adopté au sein de l'école
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui
jouent à la toupie là de plus en plus
j'ai compris qu'il y avait des ruptures
de stock dans les commerces donc on va
certainement voir le phénomène progressé
encore à la reprise des cours de fin
février
autre point remarquable de l'invasion
des toupies son côté paritaire les
filles sont elles aussi friandes de
compétition et se mesure avec plaisir
aux garçons et tout cela sans les
chamailleries habituelles
pour l'instant on n'a pas de plainte
particulière bon volume ça prend pas
beaucoup de place ça rechange facilement
dans le cartable et puis donc ça ne gêne
pas le fonctionnement de l'école ou des
cours donc de aucun aucun point négatif
à ce joue en tout cas alors vous êtes
directeur mais aussi pourquoi est-ce que
vous vous avez cédé au phénomène toupie
et ben je suis sur le point de CD mais
donc j'étais aussi moi plus ou moins lié
justement aux lois du marché donc
l'équipement va être prochain et
j'espère le plus tôt possible
de la toupie ce n'est pas spécifique à
l'archipel elle dépasse de loin nos
frontières et le Canada ou la métropole
n'échappe pas à la règle un site
internet Yémen totalement consacré si
dernière preuve s'il en est de la très
bonne santé de ce jouet qui existait
déjà dans l'antiquité
[Musique]